[Musica]
Grazie
vorrei iniziare questo racconto con voi
da un'immagine questa
un'immagine che a guardarla
probabilmente sarà suscitando in ognuno
di voi emozioni contrastanti
forse incoscienza forse coraggio forse
paura audacia
sono sicura però che ciascuno di voi
almeno una volta nella vita si è trovato
a dover fare questo un salto un salto
per affrontare un cambiamento
Se ci pensate in natura tutto cambia
tutto in costante evoluzione quindi
dovremmo essere abituati al cambiamento
dovremmo essere allenati al cambiamento
dovremmo Viverlo con leggerezza
e invece troppo spesso il cambiamento ci
fa paura
abbiamo paura dell'ignoto lo viviamo
come un salto Forse come un salto nel
buio
e invece se riusciamo ad affrontare
l'ignoto possiamo affrontare tutto e
tutti noi stessi per primi
Io vi racconterò la mia esperienza le
scelte professionali le scelte formative
della mia vita sono sempre stato
orientate al cambiamento
dagli studi classici della maturità
classica la prima scelta importante di
cambiamento è stata quella di
intraprendere un percorso di studi
scientifici qui ad Unisalento
e dopo la laurea in scienze e tecnologie
per l'ambiente ho fatto un'altra scelta
di cambiamento importante
sono tornata a quella che era la mia
prima passione cioè raccontare scrivere
ed è stato il mio lavoro per tanti anni
sono stata giornalista per 14 anni in
una importante emittente televisiva
e amavo il mio lavoro lo facevo con
passione conducevo il telegiornale di
punta andavo anche in giro realizzavo i
servizi raccoglievo le testimonianze le
interviste la gente mi riconosceva avevo
costruito anche una mia piccola
notorietà
avevo il lavoro perfetto sotto tutti i
punti di vista
a un certo punto però mi sono sentita
come in una gabbia una gabbia mentale
cioè tutto quello che avevo era reale ma
ero triste ero infelice come se non
avessi avuto nulla
e non capivo cosa fosse
non riuscivo non sapevo come uscirne
sapevo di avere dentro una luce che una
luce che credo che noi tutti abbiamo
quando si aprono in noi delle crisi
e allora ho deciso che dovevo ripartire
dovevo ricominciare dovevo reagire al
cambiamento
Sì perché spesso
le crisi interiori si aprono per i
cambiamenti imposti per i cambiamenti
indotti
nell'ambiente in cui noi viviamo quello
professionale per esempio E allora in
quel caso abbiamo due strade o
continuare su quella strada far finta di
nulla Sperando che la crisi prima o poi
passi oppure reagire come ho fatto io a
un certo punto della mia carriera
professionale ho vissuto appieno il
passaggio direi storico epocale
dall'analogico al digitale momento molto
importante per la tecnologia della
comunicazione
dal digitale in poi abbiamo iniziato ad
aggiornare in tempi rapidissimi in tempi
brevissimi in tempo reale le notizie Un
aspetto sicuramente molto bello della
comunicazione Ma la sovrabbondanza di
notizie dovuta al contesto iperconnesso
la viralità delle notizie espone il
giornalista ad un terreno insidioso
perché in qualche modo toglie
quel fascino di andare a cercare fuori
la notizia
con internet poi
i giornalisti hanno scelto sempre di più
il web la rete come fonte privilegiata
delle notizie
e questo pone è un problema di controllo
delle Fonti perché la velocità
del web Imposta dal web
detta dei tempi molto rigidi molto
serrati e spesso non permette di
controllare a fondo le fonti Ma per
controllare una fonte Ci vuole del tempo
ci vuole molto tempo Il rischio è quello
di diffondere notizie
inesatte incomplete o addirittura false
e poi oggi tutti facciamo informazione
basta avere un cellulare girare un video
trovarsi su un posto in cui è avvenuto
un episodio di cronaca qualsiasi
ed essere cronisti un aspetto anche
questo molto bello ma pone spesso un
problema di spettacolarizzazione
dell'informazione io Non dimenticherò
mai un giorno in cui fu chiamata per
raccontare un fatto di cronaca un
incidente stradale di una ragazza in cui
morì questa ragazza e non dimenticherò
mai neanche il mio disagio davanti ai
genitori di questa ragazza è il giorno
del funerale perché
perché il giornalista è tenuto e ha il
dovere di raccontare la cronaca la sua
verità la sua essenzialità
e soprattutto deve raccontare un fatto
di cronaca che sia di interesse pubblico
il cambiamento dettato invece dai tempi
che io stavo vivendo spesso ancora oggi
impongono di andare oltre la cronaca di
superare il confine della cronaca di
scavare forse un po' troppo nella vita
delle persone
ed era quello che accade a me quel
giorno
invece io credo che spesso Dobbiamo
fermarci a pensare Noi giornalisti
logiche di comunicazione che stavano
cambiando che erano cambiate e che io
non sentivo più mie non riconoscevo più
logiche di comunicazione di un
giornalismo che stava cambiando anzi che
era già cambiato e che io non sentivo
più mio
e quindi Mi direte è bastato tutto
questo
per mandare in crisi le mie certezze
lavorative professionali
bastava Tutto questo a farmi pensare che
forse era arrivato il momento di
cambiare Direi di sì nonostante quella
per me fosse un'esperienza bellissima
entusiasmante
Perché certe volte il cambiamento
dettato dall'ambiente in cui noi viviamo
ci porta a pensare che forse la strada
che stiamo percorrendo non è quella
giusta e sentiamo il desiderio di
iniziare un altro cammino
Abbiamo però mille paura
abbiamo paura dell'ignoto in qualsiasi
essere umano perso natura per sua stessa
natura Cerca sempre di allontanare
l'incertezza di non abbandonare quello
che ha costruito e preferisce rimanere
stabile sulle sue posizioni nella sua
comfort zone
e poi banalmente abbiamo paura di
sbagliare
nessuno si permette di sbagliare noi non
ci permettiamo di sbagliare pur di non
sbagliare
restiamo Dove siamo
non cerchiamo il cambiamento invece io
penso che il cambiamento ci credo che il
cambiamento dobbiamo cercare il
cambiamento dobbiamo assecondarlo perché
soltanto cercando il cambiamento
ci poniamo in una condizione di
riconoscere quelle opportunità che la
vita ci apre ci pone di fronte
opportunità di abbandonare una parte di
noi stessi e di consolidarne
riconoscerne delle altre che magari non
conosciamo
per fare questo però dobbiamo liberarci
dai nostri limiti mentali e il primo fra
tutti Io credo che sia la coerenza La
coerenza è la parte razionale di noi
quella che ci porta a proteggere sempre
le scelte che abbiamo fatto in passato
ed è spesso associata alle persone
intellettualmente stabili
l'incoerenza invece viene spesso
definita come una caratteristica
negativa della personalità Io però credo
che la coerenza sia importante e abbia
valore solo se ti aiuta a fare la cosa
giusta ma se la coerenza diventa un
ostacolo per raggiungere un obiettivo
che ci siamo prefissati diventa una
gabbia e allora in quel momento che
dobbiamo avere il coraggio di fare
scelte incoerenti
dobbiamo riuscire a trasformare la paura
di cambiare incoraggio di cambiare
dobbiamo immergerci in un'area di
incertezza Io credo
consapevoli però della nostra forza se
siamo consapevoli della nostra forza e
della nostra capacità lo possiamo fare
ed in quel momento che nasce La grande
sfida con noi stessi ed in quel momento
che scopriamo la nostra vera essenza
oggi
la comunicazione è sempre il mio campo
professionale e una comunicazione
diversa non sono più la giornalista di
prima perché sono marketing in
Communication Specialist di un'azienda
che da oltre 20 anni è nata a Lecce da
oltre 20 anni opera nel settore
dell'information Technology oggi è uno
dei Player nazionali in questo campo Ma
guardandomi indietro Sono sicura di non
aver mai avuto l'istinto di tornare
indietro è una scelta di cambiamento che
rifarei
Io credo che dobbiamo allenarci al
cambiamento lenarci ogni giorno al
cambiamento anche cambiando una nostra
piccola abitudine perché allenarci al
cambiamento oggi come oggi è importante
Vitale
c'è una frase molto significativa una
frase di Churchill
che io ricordo spesso
che dice che non è detto che cambiare
significhi migliorare ma per migliorare
dobbiamo cambiare
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]